I think the key to improv is always listening.
It’s embracing.
It’s positivity.
It’s hearing things and not shutting them
down.
It’s trying to find ways to make them work.
And in the business world I would imagine
that’s very invaluable, the idea that it’s
very frustrating just to be told no all the
time.
Improv really revolves around the idea of
like whatever you come at me with I’m going
to say yes to it.
That’s our reality.
Let’s get to work.
Let’s start there.
So just the idea of saying yes to each other
and not shutting down ideas, seeing if there’s
way to make ideas workable, making that your
default setting of like I really want to respect
what you’re saying.
See if there’s a way to take it somewhere
else versus here’s all the things that are
wrong with it.
I think it’s just a very positive mentality.
So I think a lot of people that come across
it get very addicted to it because it does
feel different, especially the New Yorker.
We’re just used to a world where everybody’s
kind of grumpy all the time and moving fast.
They don’t want to deal with each other.
The idea of showing any emotion in public,
not good.
The idea of slowing down to deal with someone
else’s ideas and emotions, not good.
Like we’re New Yorkers.
We want to get where we’re going.
So I think improv really looks at a side of
life that’s like well what if we let all
that go for a little while and just really
work on sort of positively embracing each
other’s ideas and really listening hard
to what other people have to say.
So it’s a pretty beautiful thing when it’s
going right.
Very often what you’ll see happen in improv
class is when people get nervous about how
it’s going is they’ll start saying hey
when dad gets home he’s going to be really
mad.
Or they’ll say like hey, when we get to
Reno stuff’s really going to hit the fan.
And they start saying like hey this thing
that’s going to happen or this thing like
hey, remember when you did that thing back
then?
I’m really made about it.
I think one of the things about listening
is that it’s always at its most powerful
when it’s present, when it’s right here,
when it’s right now.
And that’s a lesson about improv that I
think just made me a much more social person.
Like it just made me like when I would go
have pitch meetings I was just able to have
it better even in my personal life.
I got – when I started really thinking hard
about these improv lessons not to get weird
but like my dating like just got so much better
because the thing I always stress that I think
applies to just any conversation I always
ask people to answer these three questions
when they’re improvising.
Why these people?
Why right here?
Why right now?
I always just drill that.
Why these people?
Why right here?
Why right now?
Meaning if you’re in a scene and there’s
two people and you’re talking about people
who aren’t here like they’re not here.
They probably aren’t the most interesting
thing for an audience to hear about.
If you’re talking about a different location
than the one the scene is taking place in
then why isn’t the scene unfolding there?
It sounds more interesting.
Why are you teasing an audience?
So and another thing to people will often
go like hey, you’ll never believe what’s
inside this briefcase.
And it’s like well that’s invisible.
Let’s just talk to each other – us, things
we can find common ground whether that’s
positive things, disagreements we might actually
have.
Why are these people in this location at this
time?
Why is this the scene we’re choosing to
show the audience.
So the more we can just make things present
between the people right there, the less the
audience has to suspend their disbelief and
imagine the better the listening is going
to be and the harder it’s going to hit.
And what we find when that happens in improv
is you’re simple choices can actually get
huge reactions because if you and I were doing
a scene and I came at you and started the
scene by saying you know what?
Like everything that happened in Canada we
can never talk about it again.
That sounds like it has really high stakes.
But now the audience has to figure out well
what happened in Canada and why are we all
scared of it.
Whereas if I just looked at you and said hey,
I’m so scared and I need you to help me
through it.
That sounds like a more vague thing with less
comedic potential but an audience will go
they’re scared and you have to help each
other.
Why?
Why are they scared?
They’re scared right now and they can help
each other.
Great.
And it’s a human connection that we can
latch on to.
So being present in the moment with each other,
nothing else you’re going to work out.
It’s going to make your improv scene so
much better.
I feel it makes a lot of conversations better
too.
I’m a really big fan mainly of the phrase
slow is fast.
Slow is fast.
And what I mean by that is like especially
in the context I can speak to it in the context
of people who go on stage which is like we
forget that when we’re on stage and we’re
improvising we’re bouncing ideas back and
forth.
An audience it’s really hard for them to
keep up and they don’t really know why we’re
making the choices we’re making because
we’re trained in this and we have classes
in this.
So we can go so – to them it looks like
it’s moving a million miles an hour.
Like most people when they see an improv show
if they like it they remember that first one
as being like the best show they ever saw.
And it probably was and it’s probably just
that these people knew what they were doing
so much.
So one of the things I always like to stress
about slowing down, slowing down, slowing
down is this idea it’s actually something
that I learned from my wife who uses this
phrase because she is an aerialist.
She was an aerialist for many years.
She was a dancer who would do all this work
with harnesses and rigging and flying around
from the ceiling.
And she told me that phrase and it stuck in
my head because she always said like if you
have a problem with your harness you want
to get it fixed fast so you can go back to
the act.
You want to get back in there.
But remember to the people watching like no
matter how long it takes, no matter how slow
you move you’re still flying around in the
sky.
And I think for improv that really applies
well.
No matter how – we can really take a breath.
The audience is going to be blown away if
we do our jobs right.
We don’t need to move fast to impress them.
Like the desire is just joke, joke, joke,
laugh, laugh, laugh, laugh, laugh and you
can smother it.
That’s another think I often say about it
too is like we have to remember when we’re
improvising like it’s sort of like building
a fire.
Like you have to start with the kindling.
You have to start with just a spark.
You can’t just throw the big logs on.
If you can just try to pile anything on it’s
not going to go anywhere.
The audience is going to smell a rat and you’re
not going to be with it.
So for me I think the advice I can give anyone
is just remember someone who is a professional
doing what they do at any speed is probably
going to blow away a novice.
They’re probably going to have total control.
And when we rush we actually can give that
away.
And when we consciously take a breath and
slow down it demonstrates a confidence and
mastery of our craft which I know is a very
pretentious thing to say but that’s what
I used to say to people when I taught them
in their improv acting classes which can be
kind of pretentious.
So that’s the main thing is remember what
we do is impressive.
We don’t need to speed through it because
they’re going to be blown away as long as
we do it with integrity.